[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal d'information
locale nous sommes le lundi 14 mars au
sommaire aujourd'hui
cette nouvelle étape dans l'allègement
du protocole sanitaire ce lundi 14 mars
signe la fin du pass vaccinale et du
port du masque exception faite des
transports collectifs et des
établissements de santé comment
s'organisent les entreprises le pain
dans ce journal
collectivités particuliers ou encore
associations continuent de se mobiliser
pour l'ukraine la ville de versailles
prépare le départ de convois à
destination des réfugiés ukrainien les
camions partiront demain à 5h du matin
direction à la pologne et puis à moins
d'un mois du premier tour des
présidentielles nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des yvelinois de différentes
professions objectif connaître leurs
attentes pour les élections et pour ce
premier volet focus sur les agriculteurs
avec la maison pamiers
[Musique]
bas les masques en entreprise dans les
commerces sont encore à l'école il n'est
plus obligatoire en intérieur a compté
je vous le disais de ce lundi 14 mars
célia 400 go s'est rendu dans
l'entreprise et emitech à montigny le
bretonneux regarder
cela fait plus d'un an et demi que nous
n'avions pas vu ces images de salariés
non masqué dans une même pièce et
pourtant c'est bien réel le port du
masque n'est plus obligatoire en
entreprise depuis ce lundi 14 mars on
sait jamais vraiment habitué à voir
quelque chose
sur le visage même depuis un an ce matin
on découvre certains visages donc ça
c'est ça peut être quelque chose assez
positive nous y voilà pour améliorer les
échanges dans ce laboratoire d'essai
située à montigny le bretonneux les 150
salariés sont soulagés de la fin de
cette mesure très contraignantes pour
leur travail c'est assez compliqué au
niveau de toutes les réunions qu'on peut
avoir en visio avec les clients et aussi
le côté un peu impersonnel des échanges
pour autant dans cette entreprise la
direction n'a pas souhaité que ces
salariés enlève complètement le masque
des mesures obligatoires un terme à la
société ont été prises aujourd'hui nous
avons choisi par mesure de sécurité de
maintenir le port du masque dans
certaines conditions le port du masque
est obligatoire quand une distance de
sécurité de moins d'un mètre ne peuvent
pas être respectées ou encore lors de
tout déplacement on verra d'ici quelques
semaines comment ça évolue effectivement
pouvoir après mettre le masque
totalement de côté certains salariés
comme dans cette réunion peuvent
continuer à garder l'accessoire antico
vide s'il le souhaite enfin du masque
aussi dans les écoles et les commerces
ainsi que du passage final
et pour continuer sur ce point nous
accueillerons tout à l'heure en invité
le professeur djillali annane don qui
est le doyen de l'ufr à simone veil -le
de l'ue véhicule sera avec nous à tout à
l'heure pour en parler et après un an et
demi passé avec un masque les yvelinois
doivent se réadapter un petit peu mais
la nouvelle est plutôt bien accueillie
leur réaction au micro de nicolas
attendri et mathilde de franck ou
tel que ça me remet un peu les
mauresques parce qu'en fait je comprends
très bien réussi à parler ça va comme ça
pour ça plutôt pratique parce que déjà
on entend mieux l'épreuve effectivement
et puis du groupement nos camarades on
peut mettre du rouge à lèvres ces
pratiques et du barça bien je trouve ça
bien aujourd'hui ça fait du bien de voir
des visages et pas des masses etc je
trouve que c'est mieux parce que déjà on
voit mieux les gens à qui on s'adresse
après je trouve que ça permet de ne pas
avoir d mal de tête à la fin de la
journée parce qu'avec le mas est
vraiment c'est ses galères mais oui on
s'est un peu libérée parce que ça fait
quand même deux ans qu'on est avec le
masque et ouais c'est vrai que ça fait
du bien je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose dans le sens où bas on respire
mieux simplement maintenant j'ai pu
remarquer que pour beaucoup d'étudiants
ça a été sacré ça a été une source de
stress parce qu'on m'a jamais vu les
visages des uns et des autres et fait
rêver rêver certains complexes je pense
que c'est un soulagement un petit peu
pour tout le monde aujourd'hui on a vu
des gens heureux on a vu les gens
revivre un peu avec lui en plus le
soleil tout parfait et je pense que
moralement les j'en avais besoin c'est
un soulagement pour les commerçants pour
nous en tant que citoyens et puis en
espérant qu effectivement il n'est pas
une remise en question sur justement le
fait qu'on ne porte plus le masque à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est génial en ce
sens livre
[Musique]
et puis dans le reste de l'actualité
jeudi 10 mars la commune de
pontchartrain jouars-pontchartrain a
signé une convention sécurité avec la
gendarmerie des yvelines objectif est
bien renforcer la mobilisation des
partenaires et mettre en place des
moyens adaptés aux enjeux de sécurité de
la commune une signature qui s'inscrit
dans le cadre du programme petite ville
de demain lancée en octobre 2020 ce
programme vise à accompagner les élus
des villes de moins de vingt mille
habitants dans leur projet de territoire
et puis l'aide humanitaire envers lui
créer mais les réfugiés continuent dé
versailles et se sont proposés pour
accueillir certains d'entre eux et puis
la ville s'apprête à faire partir un
camion de dons vers la pologne un camion
qui a été chargé dès vendredi dernier
mélanie poquet et patrick jacques de
dixmude étaient sur place regarder des
diables chargé des dizaines de fois pour
remplir le camion à versailles ce
vendredi 11 mars les employés de la
mairie charge les dizaines de dons
collectés par les maisons de quartiers
de la ville nous avons onze prévu que
deux camionnettes david versailles
partent mardi résideront donc sur un
point de dispatching qui se trouve à la
frontière polonaise héros site ce sont
des camions qui viennent d'ukraine qui
récupère donc ces différents dons et qui
les emmène là où c'est utile jean
clément sort à l'un des chauffeurs
volontaires pour amener tous ces dons
c'était important moi j'aime bien aider
les gens en difficulté
ça me permet de voir un petit peu aussi
les aider de ramener de finitude de
une collecte organisée avec
l'association école ukrainienne de
paris-saint volodymyr une association
qui donne depuis vingt ans des cours à
de jeunes ukrainiens arrivée en france
je fais un appel la ville de versailles
qui est très généreuse et je veux
remercier du fond du coeur pour tous que
les versaillais
nous apporte aujourd'hui les camions qui
trouve versailles ce mardi 15 mars à 5
heures du matin 1800 km à parcourir pour
atteindre leur destination
et pour soutenir les ukrainiens le
département des yvelines a voté une aide
de 200 mille euros une subvention qui
vise à soutenir l'opération des convois
humanitaires pour l'ukraine elle a été
lancée par l'omg française acted est là
pour objectif d'acheminer de l'argent et
puis du matériel de première nécessité
sur place un appel au dos donc un appel
aux dons donc qui a été lancé à début
mars et plus d'informations vous pouvez
les retrouver sur le site acted acted
point org et nous sommes à présent à un
mois à peu près des preuves des premiers
tours des présidentielles
al'approche des élections nous sommes
allés à leur rencontre des yvelinois
pour connaître leurs attentes et nous
commençons notre tour avec les
agriculteurs alors moins de charges plus
d'être de l'état privilégiée peut-être
l'agriculture de proximité qu'attendent
finalement et les agriculteurs yvelinois
de leur futur président et bien c'est
sûr le reportage de mathilde et franck
ou thomas premier gérant de l'eurl
maison pamiers l'exploitation agricole
située à orgeval notre ferme a été donc
créé par une par an en 1978 ils sont
arrivés ici avait seulement
seulement des chaumes de blé ils ont
tous bâtis donc les bâtiments les serres
et ils sont implantés les vergers et
puis développer la culture du maraîchage
sur le plateau des allures notre
exploitation agricole fait 27 hectares
nous avons sur 27 hectares des légumes
et du fruit donc en arboriculture pommes
poires prunes fruits rouges ça ça
correspond à près de 1,4 hectare de
notre salut et le reste en maraîchage
avec un peu d'abri fra bat comme suit
dans lequel on est on a un petit hectare
d'abris froid voilà pour faire l'hiver
bat de la salades des radis
de la mâche et en saison on fait tous
nos produits d'été les tomates
aubergines
oui on a quand même des attentes au
niveau des élections on l'espère le
maintien de la dynamique avec les aides
à l'investissement qu'on peut avoir par
le département la région l'europe où des
êtres sur investissement de matériel ou
d'alternative aux produits
phytosanitaires qui nous aident à
moderniser nos entreprises au quotidien
et puis on attend également
une réduction de charges au maximum sur
nos entreprises ce qui nous permettra de
garder la trésorerie sur nos entreprises
pour embaucher du personnel pour
continuer à moderniser l'entreprise et
améliorer les conditions de travail de
nos collaborateurs
est toujours dans le cadre des
présidentielles et bien ce week-end
était placée sous le signe de la
mobilisation pour les militants des
partis politiques puisque des
rassemblements et des porte à porte et
est organisé dans les yvelines ce samedi
12 mars notamment les militants
yvelinois de la majorité présidentielle
se sont donné rendez vous à 14 heures au
marché notre dame de versailles c'est
est un rassemblement pour lancer
officiellement la campagne avec vous
êtes dans le département et puis
d'autres rassemblements et porte à porte
ont lieu en dans le département ce
week-end un reportage à découvrir
prochainement sur tv 78
et côté sport c'est la fenêtre la plus
connue des réseaux sociaux la lucarne à
d'evry dans l'essonne c'est une petite
fenêtre d'un local poubelle au 24 rue
jules vallès transformer en cage de
football depuis 2000 19 des amateurs
tente l'exploit dit marqué un but et
après un engouement des vidéos sur
internet et bien des personnalités s'y
sont essayés et aujourd'hui c'est même
une tournée partout en france qui est
organisé la dernière escale en date à
poissy ce week-end le reportage de
wilfrid richy et céline charles un carré
de 43 cm sur un mur de 9 mètres de long
pour 2 mètres 62e au un seul objectif y
faire passer un ballon de football en un
minimum de tentatives un défi lancé à
evry dans l'essonne durant le
confinement et qui aujourd'hui fait le
tour de la france
[Musique]
nous sommes en 2010 neuf premières
vidéos de la lucarne d'evry qui réalise
un véritable buzz sur internet les
habitants du quartier tente chaque jour
de réussir l'exploit
puis c'est au tour de personnalités de
s'illustrer comme l'ancien attaquant du
psg nenê
[Applaudissements]
que le lieu de galles populaires comme
ça ça ce mot c'est un gros plus pour
nous et pour la ville tu d'autant plus
qu'on est à dévier un quartier difficile
aux tirs amis es du match voilà je
voulais assez mal réputé et pas des
faits divers ou des fesses violence et
de faire parler d'un bilan bien
sérieusement ça
et maintenant evry s'exporte dans plus
de 30 villes de villiers le bel en
passant par poissy avec une
reconstitution grandeur nature du mur et
l'organisation d'un championnat et on en
profite aussi pour mettre des ateliers
en poids des ateliers santé serait en
sorte que le plaisir plus puissent être
conjuguées avec de l'utilité derrière le
comédien et humoriste alban ivanov
originaire des yvelines étaient aussi
présents pour assurer le spectacle à la
lucarne passera prochainement par
marseille avec une finale nationale pour
les meilleurs joueurs qui se déroulera
au juillet à evry
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael elle me d'euros pour
votre magazine sportif il sera
accompagné de bixente mais rien sont
esteban pour vos résultats du week-end
très bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh